so what do you think it is about Five
Nights at Freddy's that has caused it to
be so popular for like the last 10 years
oh man uh that's a huge question that I
don't know if I'm fully equipped to
answer but what I will say is that I
felt really completely addicted to it
once I started playing it so I
understand why everyone else would have
as well um but I think what is also such
a big part of of the FNAF franchise is
the online community and the way the
fans like to theorize about the lore and
talk to each other and engage and and
that's just huge and unique and
fantastic what do you think would
surprise fans of blumhouse to learn
about making a blumhouse movie
interesting I'm throwing curveballs
that's a big curveball well I will say
specifically for this one the way in
which our schedule uh was blocked out
the first month we weren't filming with
the animatronics we were filming in
locations and it almost felt like we
were filming a family drama because we
had a lot of scenes that were you know
Mike and Abby brother and sister going
through some real grounded human um
struggles and a month into production we
moved into the pizzeria uh set and
started filming with the animatronics
and that was a whole a whole tail spin
so in the best of in best of ways but I
think for a horror film you know this
has a lot of genre blending as well and
um and maybe that's not as expected for
every blumhouse film for there's going
to be a generation of kids that this is
their first scary movie what does that
actually mean to you oh that's huge I
mean I I feel really honored that this
might be kind of an initiation into that
type of um film I certainly remember the
films that you know scared me the most
as a kid and I I think they hold a
special place in my heart uh because of
that but they also like thinking back on
films like Gremlins and stuff there
there were films that also had so much
uh wonderment humor and in in the case
of Grandma's cuteness and then these
things turn these cute things turn into
monsters and I think we were also trying
to create that tonal blend that is I I
think really uh special sauce sure the
the film's PG-13 yeah you get away with
one pretty good kill one that's like I
was like oh you know what I mean um so
I'm just curious about what it's like
making a film like this that might
Teeter on the edge and negotiating with
the MPAA yeah I mean it's an ongoing
conversation from the script process to
editorial uh to any VFX enhancements uh
to make sure that we're we're walking
that line of what Our intention is and
really wanting to deliver for the fans
on the scares and um and also still
being able to fall into that PG-13
category so it's just like adding a
little bit of salt adding a little bit
of pepper oh did we add too much okay
we'll pull it back you know it's
figuring out the blend did you actually
have to negotiate because there's a
sequence with spec I don't want to
reveal anything but did you have to
negotiate with them on that or like or
any other sequence to get the pg3 we
were we were doing pretty well in terms
of like sticking the execution right um
in terms of of still qualifying for the
PG-13 but it was all execution dependent
um so for instance one of the moments
that you're referring to we used a lot
of Shadow work and you know that was a
way in which we were able to get around
it but I think for for this film and and
our cinematic approach I think it was a
more creatively satisfying choice anyway
so I was actually really excited to to
be figuring out ways to make it PG-13
friendly so I love talking about the
editing process cuz it's where it all
comes together so what did you learn
from like early screenings that impacted
the finished film you know um we were
highly aware that um security leaks were
an issue on this one so we were pretty
close to our chest but you know I would
say the biggest thing in terms of some
feedback that we got that we ended up
reshaping a bit was the ending um just
in terms of the balance of of character
action um so we we brought out a little
bit more of of Mike's active role at the
end of the film based on some feedback
which was really really helpful so this
is obviously something this movie is
really anticipated by a huge audience
and I'm just curious with planting
Easter eggs that could be used in the
future in case you guys get to make
another one was that something that you
were thinking about while filming or is
it sort of like we just got to focus on
one film at a time time we were
definitely focused on planting Easter
eggs throughout but I think it was
mostly in an effort to make sure that
the first one was full of them for the
fans um on the first View and hopefully
on the second and third view too just
continual things to discover should
people want to rewatch it um less
concerned with how it might impact uh
potential sequels but of course that's
been in the back of our head too and
hopefully we'll be lucky enough to
explore that when people watch this is
there a sequence that they should
specifically look out for that maybe has
something in the background that you
might not immediately see I would say
check out the security
monitors okay fair enough uh you got to
work with Jim Henson's uh Creature Shop
yeah which is amazing yeah so talk a
little bit about collaborating on
creating the animatronics and what you
could and maybe couldn't do with them on
set well Sky was kind of the limit I
mean we were we were pushing all the
boundaries and figuring out how best to
bring these things to life and um you
know there was a ton of rehearsal we
were figuring out how long the servos
could last when we were doing like
extensive movements on stage with the
animatronics so there were always
parameters uh and things that needed to
be considered but we were a pretty fine
oiled Machine by the end of production
and all of the time it took to Prep Prep
the animatronics and break them down and
all that just like severely reduced over
the course of production because
everyone was just getting it getting it
down to a science hypothetically I know
you wouldn't have taken anything from
set but what did you take from
[Laughter]
set I shall never speak of that did you
did you attempt to get one of the
animatronics in the car or was it do it
way too much well we actually did put an
animatronic in a car for a scene and
that was a massive undertaking so uh I
don't know if you could fit one in a
normal car think it would need to be
disassembled before you do that but it
was really fun doing it for the scene
yeah I uh this is one of those things
where uh I would want to try to you know
borrow one just to keep it home you know
what I mean uh did you end up with a lot
of deleted scenes no actually you know
we we really
used pretty much all the scenes that we
shot um I you know certain things got
shortened of course as they do in the
editorial process every time but I we
didn't leave anything on The Cutting
Room floor on this one and everything
felt like it really had a purpose and um
and worked well in the film which was
incredible yeah yeah because I thought
Josh really went for it like he really
delivered so talk a little bit about his
performance in the movie because if he's
not anchoring everything the whole thing
comes apart that's a th% right uh if you
are not with Mike then you've you you
you're lost in the film and Josh was
really just the the perfect mic so lived
in so um sure of himself and comfortable
in the character and um he himself as a
performer has so much depth has so much
light-heartedness like all of these
things that Mike needed to have that are
that are not always easy to come by and
and in one performance and he just
nailed it uh last thing for you uh Scott
was on Set uh and is it good having the
Creator on set or is there a little bit
of like nervousness because he might
want to be like well that's not perfect
you know we got do you know what I mean
no it was great I mean if if he wasn't
on set he had access to you know seeing
what our our monitors were doing and I
was really really happy to be having the
feedback in real time if there was
anything that we needed to
adjust um but he said a very nice thing
to me a couple weeks into production he
was like I'm really sitting back and
enjoying the movie um and kind of
watching you know watching the process
unfold or the story unfold on screen um
which was amazing cuz of of course you
know he didn't know what to expect
necessarily walking into it and and it
was my time first time working with him
so I didn't either you know in terms of
actually shooting and and being in
communication and I think it was a
fantastic process but like just a huge
asset to have him in our Corner because
I don't think we could have done a an
accurate adaptation of this this game
without him on that note I really hope
it's a huge hit for you thank you so
much and thank you for giving me your
time appreciate it nice to meet
you